[音楽]
[拍手]
ああ、ありがとうございまし
たCSですCS申し訳ありませんCSは
チェロとシンセサイザーの略です
本当に シンプル私は知っ
ているので、私の名前はShuHaeckelZazaです
。Shuと呼んでください。ごめんなさい。
彼はいとこのいたずらなコラーダです。今日はカズーと呼んでください。
私たちは音楽が大好き
で、一緒に演奏してあなたと共有することを考えていた
ので、今日は私自身の音楽の旅をあなたに共有するためにここにいます
私の音楽の旅は
私が生まれたときから始まりました私の
家族全員が古典的な家族です
クラシックを始めたので
、ここでこの楽器を始めました。チェロ
とクラシックはこんな感じです
[音楽
]誰もがそのようなフレーズをどこかで聞いたことがあると思います。
同時にそれは
静かです ほとんどの場合、
私はそれに飽き飽きしてい
ました。私が始めたときは5〜6歳だったので、
小さな子供だったので、あまり練習しませんでした。
代わりに、コンピューター
でゲームをして、好きでした。
私がゲームをした音楽で、そのジャンル
はテクノと呼ばれていました。こうして
私は電気的な音楽に堪能になり
、このようなアコースティックな音ではなく電気的な
音が出るようなものを見つけたので、
本当に夢中になりました。 それに
夢中になって、人生の半分くらいテクノを聴いていて、
10年くらい経ちました。それから日本に
来ました。高校でこれに行くために日本に来ました
。そこでカズーと出会いました。
私は彼が私が持っていないものを持っていることを知っていた
ので、彼に
クラシックとテクノを与え、彼は私にこの
ような音のポップとロックを与え
ました
[音楽]
それはもう少し幸せな音を持っているので
遊ぶのは本当に楽しいです でも彼に
はたくさんの音楽があり、私にはたくさんの音楽があったからです
彼と一緒に持っていく
のにかなりの時間がかかったので
、私が過ごした高校の3年間は
主に音楽についてでした。それから
大学に入学し、
音楽についてもっと知りたいと思っていたジャンルに本当に飢えていました。
私はジャズを演奏し始めました
、そしてそれが私がこの大きなバリトンサクソフォンを演奏し始めた方法です
そしてジャズは
このようなものを演奏し始めましたそれは一種のポップのように聞こえます
がそれはまだそれにこのスイングを持っています
今はジャズが大好きです。
テクノよりもクラシックよりもポップ
やロックよりも好きです。他の
ジャンルも好きですが、これが
一番好きなので、今日は
言葉だけでなくお見せします。
でも、
この3つの楽器または4つの楽器を使った音楽の旅を紹介するためにもここにいる
ので、楽しん
で始めましょう。
クラシックな曲を演奏します。この曲を聞いたことがある方もいらっしゃると思います
が、
[音楽]
[音楽]を参照してください
そしてそれは古典的で
、次のステップに移りましょう
テクノ
[音楽]
[音楽
]テクノはこれほど電気的な音
を持っていて、この種のすり減る音
を持っています。
次のポップとロックに移りましょう
[音楽]
それでいいので
、私が言ったように私の一番好きなジャズジャズに移り
ます。私たち二人がとても愛している曲を紹介したいと思います。
[音楽]
それが私の音楽の旅でした私
たちは再びCESです彼はカサであり私は確かです
本日は良い一日をお過ごし
ください。ありがとうございました
[拍手]